[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
very excited to be talking about data
isn't data data is trust we're gonna be
talking about FinTech I'll be talking
about modeling analysis very excited to
have Damian Walden joining us on the
show hello Alan thank you so much for
the kind invitation great to be her very
excited very grateful for Rachel haywire
for introducing us and I love your
background this is gonna be very
exciting Damian's got 20 years in
experience in data science in product
management business development
financial services in real estate
he's the currently the founder of the
molybdenum which is an innovation
practice centered on data analytics and
risk management where he is a strategic
adviser to several fintax
so let's start things off with this big
history take on civilization we find
ourselves as stewards of earth what's
your current take on the human
experiment well um oh and I think we've
got some work to do and I guess that
work and that set of tasks and
activities is very much centered within
ourselves as people and our own personal
journey I know my own personal
experience but also enveloped out to the
communities and whether they're family
societies organizations businesses which
are however whatever collectives we
ascribe to and we believe we are we're
members of so I think the journey in
humanity always has to start in put
places and the success of humanity I
feel very much is around the convergence
of those two journeys so that me asked
in equilibrium in a sense between one's
personal residents happiness acceptance
position in the world and and those
around you or those whether there are
concentric circles in that linear model
or [ __ ] tiles or whatever there the
geometry of community is these days or
any day that sense of equilibrium Cree
essence if you like is I think we're
where we should be heading whether we
are heading
there is a is of course the issue in the
problem annex I really enjoy how you
make it this it's against the Nash
equilibrium you know the the balance
between the individual
self-actualization the collective
self-actualization yeah I think so on
and I think if if we've learned anything
at all from the last you know five 10 15
years you know network ization that
there's there's too many eyes ations I
totally absent during this conversation
but someone's going to come up with what
a few more economic set of syllables
right because economics is about
reductionism in part and there's another
set of syllables but you know the idea
of collectives networks communities were
where are we in relation to the others
which you know classically was about
just me and you right and what was
outside so now we think of this wider
communitarian space and that's really
really a good and positive thing but of
course that works bring complexity they
don't necessarily think a simplicity all
right so that's where I think things
just get more complicated and more
multi-layered and that's the challenge I
think we find and in many many areas of
our engagement with the world and indeed
ourselves and humanity more generally
yeah and then it was also cool how you
were in attendance at the the TEDx
Sanford's right we're also you speak for
the first time last fall indeed the and
that was on the art powerful questions
and yes you also are really fascinated
with questions and get like powerful
questions and you sent me this really
good philosophy quote so tell us about
why you're also very fascinated with the
power of the question rather than
answers today
I think questions are generative so
they're they're they're they're almost
like auto generative engines you know
they they expand they take us forward
they take us to another place and in
fact I don't know if you're familiar
with the work of Jacob Needleman for
example and
the meaning of Erath and philosophy of
money and so on but he is very very
centered on this point of how how the
idea of the question there you know the
kind of a philosophy of the question was
actually a major driver of civilization
and of course Google's whole business
was the farthest um on search aka
questions right you're querying the
collective knowledge you're querying the
collective knowledge and that's where
again to come back to the point of
convergence where data and analytics
meet question and questioning yeah
because a query a database query is
precisely that a question right but
obviously um in a vocabulary of data
information and code right so what we've
been working with I feel over the last
10 15 20 years is where technology now
becomes the questioning engine right and
we effectively trade some of our own
autonomy perhaps to get a better
questioning engine because as human
beings you know in a revolution it has
largely been about questioning and that
being the impetus to drive us forward so
now we have a set of tools in technology
and data in databases and sewn together
with all the constraints and limitations
and enable us and all things that you
know you and I and many people know so
well but but but that's what you want
it's about you know talking about it
from this this big history perspective
we have this collective body of
knowledge that we've accumulated over
time and it's grown the but the edge of
knowledge has continued to go outward
and out right over time and now we're
talking about the ability one's ability
to query it which is kind of what was
the cool thing about Google and Baidu
and stuff is just you can query that
collective body of knowledge and then
that way you can more easily get your
question answered about what you want to
learn about and again so when someone
potentially asks you about like what's
the role of like a kidney in the human
body or whatever that you can now more
easily more quickly have the answer to
the to the question but even then versus
if someone you just said
that oh the kidney does this and that
might only be 10 or 30 percent of total
answer right so you can keep going in
depth and even more depth and and let's
start talking about this in the data
perspective because there's a couple
interesting things wasted to take this
on with let's say you can apply like
something like a Pareto distribution to
the answer of like what a kidney does in
the human body and you might want to
find only the 20% of the answer that
gives you 80% of the knowledge about
right kidney right and that's very very
important in the business world for
example that there's an optimization
driver and efficiency driver
productivity driver to actually find out
where that 20% or that you know X
percent is so that you're not wasting
your time you know in this sort of
random but semi random spread the things
that either don't make you money or
don't drive you forward or don't satisfy
your customer whatever you know space it
is that you that you're trying to
address but I think it just for you
again for from a business standpoint you
know that equation of you know a
business question you know who should I
market to what are my products all the
things that that an enterprise has to
wrestle high medium and low has to
wrestle with it day after day that that
can be expressed in a query that a query
is the business question and therefore
the answer to that question is a set of
answers to those that a question or
basically what what a data repository or
a database repository is now of course
that immediately then brings up the
whole point as you have it in any kind
of search paradigm is you how far do you
go in the search who controls the search
obviously now we have paid search right
so search can be adjusted with other
objectives right so so the that's a huge
question who controls the search who
controls the search and you know I
worked in market research for many many
years in the UK and we you know any
market research will make that
distinction between the open-ended
question you know on the closed question
the closed question is a set of codes
you know you know what's your scale of
one to ten or what's your highest
preference for the open question is you
know what do you like about a car you
know
so questions come with whole apparatus
around governments around transparency
so yes they drive us forward but they
remind me a little bit I think it was am
Howard Evans who was the editor of the
London Times many years and it was very
very focused on photojournalism for
example and I remember alive he wrote in
the book or interviewers something like
that or he said you know the camera
doesn't lie but it can be an accessory
to untruth you know and I think of
questions like that a question of itself
doesn't have a truth value and in the
philosophical as a logical sense but the
way the question is posed and hence the
way a query is an interpretation of that
can be an accessory to unintended
consequences in unattended consequence
in the Shelby site we have to we have to
be very honest with how not everything
carries the same value that's this thing
you can tag value to certain data right
that may be this this understanding of
big history is a very valuable data for
every child that's born into the world
but to know one person that did one
thing on a farm a thousand years ago or
a couple hundred years ago might not be
like knowing their name and what they
didn't might not be as important as
knowing this understanding a big history
right so there's all these kind of of
values that we need to ascribe to data
we sure do I think it was one of us who
said that human life of itself is not
important our values make itself and and
consequently the the inscription of
value to a question and to a response to
a question or search and responses to
question is very important indeed it's a
whole branch of philosophy axiology that
is devoted to that and of course
economics for example as the madam
ization madam eyes not in that a
cessation of value
and I said and all of the convention
pieces of that is it's critical to the
way our society and our world is
organized and it's driven forward or
backward and it depending on the set of
constraints applicable at that time so
in terms of understanding what is value
and the very close link to that between
value or the link between value and
values it is critical I think for human
understanding and in particular for
pedagogy and you mentioned yes children
are young children and you know there's
a globe behind me here which how many
young children or adults even you know
touch that or get little version of that
as people of my generation did as kids
so um what's the sense of unity that
that brings yeah and I think you know it
you mentioned a little bit distraught
about data being trust and you know that
relationship between data and Trust and
data and Justin values is critical and
in fact I would submit that even within
any relationship or of any sport its the
values that are the glue and the unit
and the set of unifier is between two
people between a person and their
community between B and O to whatever
two entities are what are the shared
values you know what is the how are
those share bodies articulated how how
do they grow how do they come into
equilibrium with each other that that is
that's you know to come back to
Automator that's acceptance that's
quiescence
that's maybe happiness yeah that's so
well said that that question about core
values for both an individual for a
community for a family for an for a
nation for the globe what are the core
values and we see that very much so as
an individual taking one's core values
and actual izing them into the world we
see ones on a planetary level the
importance of having this big history
perspective be one of those central core
values so that we actually realize how
we are all in this union with evolution
and with each other on this one rock
orbiting the star and then you started
hinting at that governance and law and
who owns these substrates
we write that we query for data who owns
the substrates that we go into virtually
into the the virtual realities and
worlds who who owns the general
intelligences that are of the future
because those become then the most power
right and you you know if we go back to
the 18th century and so and the contract
says yeah you know the the idea of a
contract which of course is a kernel of
law is about two parties coming together
and agreeing a set of principles
constructs and then agreeing to behave
or or build something together in that
way so you know we have a social
contract which maybe fray at the edges a
points but what is our data contract you
know what is our data contract and in
order to enter to enter into a contract
it fundamentally is the formalization of
trust you know or the articulation of
trust in in in written form and that's
also clickable even in inbox writing for
example yes smart contracts they are
still contracts right they are
codifications of of agreement and hence
code for creating codifications of
sharings
its codification of values yeah so you
know when you peel the onion there are
those two dolls or whoever you want to
get into that you know from the mantle
of the earth to the core and that's
that's really what it is so I think yeah
and so this is just you know critically
important I think it's a to church or
where we're going and how we get there
it's it's great how one can then have an
understanding of values shared values
value is then could be seen as a data
that let's say that you and I both have
the data piece of like of not wanting to
bop each other over the head or whatever
again yeah etc and then that's a shared
that becomes a shared value and then
that becomes like a social contract or
potentially like a just another trust
contract that we have with each other
right and this is where I think
mathematics numerix data of course not
all data is is quantitative there's a
yeah yeah you know I'll see what are the
examples of data that's not coins I'm
unstructured data text language visuals
you know that that may be true a
reductionist set of techniques are
indeed methodologies can be reduced to G
numerix but you know the classic
paradigm is both qualitative and
quantitative data structured and
unstructured data
but even if we in a vast majority of
data today is on structure design
structured right and that includes all
the text that we put on absolutely this
conversation is like visuals and
pictures and and of course that in terms
of data explosion over the last you know
five ten years it's primarily being true
pictures and videos and an unstructured
and structured qualitative type
information but just come back to the
qualitative for moment which is where my
training and and background is you know
when you really to drill into the
concept of number itself which of course
is at the kernel of mathematics we're
talking earlier a little about share
value and how important that it's for
any kind of relationship or contractual
or agreeableness your number itself is
both you know singular and plural you
know you know in the sense when we say
one two three four five six seven you
know that has a uniqueness as a number
but it also applies to a plurality of
objects you know so in fact even even
when you go back to and I did it did the
19th century when logician started to
look at a number at star 2 and then
later Bertrand Russell and folks in the
early 20th century that idea of number
being almost like a little bit like a
hologram that you think of the idea of a
hologram which is both in itself and for
itself that you know the entire universe
is contained in that hologram but yet
itself as a point in the universe you
know and I've always been very very
fascinated about you know that
relationship between the singular and
the plural the individual society the
data point and its environment you know
that whole you know
these model is these models that that
are are you know not binary but um and
which which again you you know which are
continuous which are a spectrum or
spectrum eyes but but it's but but every
complicated and you know in itself to
even even think of them as you know most
of the of the way we do our analysis of
course is to reduce dimensionality and
and simplify things so that we have you
know indeed there's a principle in in
analytics and machine learning that
would go parsimony which is kind of a
fancy way of saying meaningless right
that we want to build the most
sophisticated models but use the least
amount of data or the least amount of
attributes or the least amount of
primitive elements to understand right
and and there's some very good reasons
for that because they're more
intelligible they're more have higher
explanatory power so there is a there is
a benefit of taking the most relatable
and most structured and rid kind of
reductionist ways of seeing things and
that's kind of like a compression of the
most valuable aspects and then teaching
that there's a high value in that but
then if one does want to go deeper than
they can see them yeah I think you use
an interesting word there Allen a
compression because you know when you
compress a file it's for storage reasons
or for cost reasons because you don't
have the space or you know you you you
want to limit your computational
overhead to calculation or a piece of
analytics but of course what's what's
really important is that when you
compress you don't lose something right
and that you know it's sort of equates
to you know when you when you have an
eye test if you do your annual eye
tester the eye test we're all supposed
to do each each year and you sit in it's
a town of the chair and they have this
machine against your foreign door this
apparatus against your forehead and your
cheeks and so on and then the
ophthalmologist puts in all these
different lenses and is that better is
that weaker and so on and then super
sooner or later you get a set of lenses
to say okay bingo I'm done here you know
so what I think what am
analyst dozen which I would advocate we
should all do and do more of is know
your lenses you know what what do you
actually seem true and that it's your
hands that are on those lenses and
putting them in and putting them out and
you know doing the adjustments and so on
because that's how we should see this is
so good that we have our own autonomy at
that and then again in agreement we make
sure to where we make care of rather to
trade some of that autonomy for other
types of utility or value yes but that
it starts with us yes this is such a
good analogy because when you take a
this these changes in lenses at like an
eye doctor that one can also see I've
for now several years had this
illustration that I've been aiming to to
get more and more into the mimetic
sphere just that when you have a
complicated issue like immigration or
health care or whatever it is at the
center that's just the one issue that
you're taking into account but then you
have all of the complex like you have
what a twenty-year-old thinks what a
sixty-year-old thinks about health care
then you have what an Indian person
feels what a person from France feels
what a person from China feels etc about
the issue and then low socioeconomic
status high socioeconomic status medium
and so what you're doing is you're
changing your lenses you're viewing
healthcare from the perspective of low
SES high SES China etc and if you can do
that really well right that's when you
can get behind other people's eyes
that's when you can understand the
nuance of these complicated issues and
how to best write and you know in that
sort of spectrum of of diversification
which societally is is around diversity
Richard which is also critical but you
know one of the challenges with that is
that not all those lenses are equal
right that's the next is the idea of
that gatekeeper lens that you know maybe
that's in the fun position maybe that's
in the back position or
perónism in that land stack you know
that has more weight there's a gradient
effectively between that you know uber
lands or super lands compared to those
others and then that's where the issue
of governance and and control and and
consent and you know the data contract
that I've been talking about let me see
if I can tackle an interesting aspect of
the of the lens is not all beings is
equal value how about if you have proven
let's say that you have a very strong
abstract perspective on civilizations
evolution and what the future of
healthcare is in terms of preventive
medicine and precision medicine and
maintaining the body and homeostatic
capacity of like a 25 year old to your
whole life whatever right that if you
can think about what I just said right
that's a pretty good compression of what
an ideal perspective on health care is
right right so now the question is how
many of those then nodes looking at the
central node of health care see it like
that right and so then that's then the
question of how much how much of a
strong futuristic but also taking in the
history in the in the present of a
perspective one has on the issue and
then you one can also put that weighted
value of that perspective is actually
that lens is actually stronger and we
need a guide more children towards that
lens well there's a beautiful line in
virtual Breck's play Galileo
where Galileo invites some of the e to
the florentine of the Milan nobility and
the Cardinals and bishops and so on to
look through his telescope right and he
says something I've got a power phrase
it here but just look because if you
look you'll see what I see and they
don't look and of course that ultimately
leads him
the Inquisition and and everything that
eventuated from from that process so you
know part I think of the the data
contract is an injured part of any
contract contract or or shared values is
seeing it as the other person sees it
yes right you know putting yourself into
someone else's shoes right and for me
there's no loss of authenticity or
autonomy in that indeed it's part of
questioning right because you know
you're good I would submit that you're
questioning actually gets an accelerant
or if you know utilizes an accelerator
concerns acceleration by precisely do
not because you're you're sort of your
your set your question maybe it's just a
lever is an excerpt whereas when you
have that question from the others
perspective then becomes a full question
yeah you know and and and that's where I
think you know the the learning true
date and the learning true shared values
in this get a contract idea um you know
so is so important so critical
we spent so much time talking about
lenses and this is like kind of models
as well these are those models are ways
of representing the world and ways of
looking at the world or looking into the
world yeah I can already tell that I
really love the way that you see things
this mental lattice that you carry cuz
we have that similar perspective and on
the data side as well as on the truth
side on what's true and how to compress
truth into the most relatable ways for
potentially even for seeds for the seeds
of children that are coming into the
world right now
take us down Damian's journey so the
personal the professional journey of
this fascination with data with finance
with models with analysis with real
estate finances how to take us here yeah
sure thank you um so certainly as a
student at school and back in Ireland
yes science and in particular physics
what was my first love and although
while I love chemistry too and in fact I
think many chemists say that chemistry
is a scientist science you know that
there's something about the purity of
the scientific method in chemistry that
isn't necessarily the case in in other
areas but um but leaving on a side for a
second physics was it was kind of where
it was that for me and of course not and
applied math in particular is kind of
language language of that and I very
much thought at that time you know in
undergrad that my career my life would
be centered in a school or college
university is a you know researcher
professor in physics in whatever branch
and you know off to the races with that
but people make a difference and I had a
wonderful maths teacher and professor
Brendan Goldsmith who really instilled
me of love of mathematics for its own
sake right and he was very instrumental
in me moving to that route but still
with very applied roots you know so pure
mathematics but applied by Baxter to use
that classical distinction so in grad
school you know it was numerical
analysis and
the idea of approximation methods that I
spent a lot of time on and you know it's
interesting we were talking about binary
and binary versus you know the on off
versus bris multivariate versus
continuity and so on and it was
something I'm in my graduate work that
was really at the core of what I was
doing I'm computing wise algorithm wise
and so on the idea of what is an
approximation right which in turn is a
representation or representation of a
representation and the particular area
of math that I was focused on find out
different methods a branch of numerical
analysis is saying you know here's a
curve is a yeah here's some that lateral
representation you know there's no
breaks there's no on/off there it's it's
a continuous function as we say in that
but now when we want to approximate that
we effectively sample it at different
points right and then build an
approximation model and that's a model
that we can code and run in a computer
and so on and get an answer and then of
course we map the the actual which is
pure and continuous to the projection
which of course is discrete so that idea
of what we called and I believe is still
called discretization right so moving
from spectrum and continuum effectively
to a set of nodes or points is something
that I still carry with me to this day
and I think is really at the heart of
any analytics because you know when
you're tackling as I am for clients you
know a business problem that data is not
a complete description of their world
their market their customers their
opportunity it's it's a subset or it's
an approximation it's a representation
so how do we go from that discretization
and its engine and apparatus to truth
which is really the entire world you
know so I think I've always been very
very fascinated and involved and
configured around you know trying to
come up with that answer and and again
it sort of maps on to some of the things
we've been talking about in this
conversation the ended even of the
individual society
this and than that and really I suppose
in a more abstract level the
relationship between the part and the
whole
yeah you know yeah and you know that the
single plural so that's kind of like can
I sleep I can let me see let me saying
break this again on summarize if I can
paraphrase then it means I can
that means I'm learning at least a
little bit in a kindergarten okay so in
a business sense as well we can see
things like that spectrum so the non
binary the spectrum perspective the
continuum and then for the business
they're trying to potentially tackle
something like if we make this
advancement in research and development
will people from in the markets actually
desire to use this right advancement and
then the question then becomes we need
to take like you said from that go from
this seven point eight billion potential
people using this thing to let's find
the nodes these these smaller
individuals as well as communities of
people in different places and seeing
will they actually take this on will
they actually use this right research
and development time yeah I mean that's
that's that's one paradigm you know in
the business space for that but also
again more generically forecasting what
is the future and in forecasting you
know is is the mathematics of the future
and not in the sense that it's it's it's
it's it's where math will be in the
future but it's the apparatus it's it's
the application of math to the future
you know so any form of projection any
yes any form of yes the sun will come
out tomorrow'
okay so we were talking about the
grounds for that and then what's the
analytic apparatus that gives us
confidence so you're making that point
you're applying the math to the future
in the sense of if you have a potential
of Damian's life and you see Damian
stayed in Ireland right versus came to
Silicon Valley and maybe started
surrounding himself with really high
power high influence in people and
companies out here that maybe
the trajectory in terms of overall
influence would have potentially been
slightly angled lower over time than
higher so people make these decisions
all the time
with even the food they put in their
body right am i gonna eat a bunch of
refined sugar right now my Health's
gonna go doo-doo-doo-doo versus if I eat
the salad then it's gonna project upward
mathematically yeah I mean I mean
there's a point that's made in the in
the philosophy of science that facts are
theory latent you know that there's no
such thing as a a non theorized fact
that the very articulation of fact the
very collection of data implicit in that
is a theory right and and consequently a
view about how that will behave going
forward you know the present this moment
is future Laden right it may not be
future oriented and again in the
Analects of this i mean you even go back
to you know sixteenth seventeenth
century and you know what newton and
leibniz and all those folks were
wrestling but at the time and you know
that that will achieve the Leibniz in
their monad you know which had you know
past present future and probably doing a
little bit of a disservice all in the
one Bowl you know to get to give it a
geometric picture so I think you know
that's where you know that point of
decisioning and also the risk of making
decision based on a model comes in right
because a model based on date is a
representation of reality you project
and take a set of decisions or go
forward based on that but you know again
in classical statistics or classical
math on that there is an error term you
know that model can be wrong and the
goal of of of of working with data
networks is as much I would submit you
understand that error and where that
error is most prevalent in the
representation of the sub representation
of the space that you're bringing your
your math kit to and an analyst who
doesn't do that is sort of doing it to
service 200 cells and to the people
they're working with understanding the
errors are as important as understanding
the signals absolutely yeah and if we
even look back at the last financial
crisis
which you you know we spend a lot of
work in the in the arena Stadium and and
flange markets at the time you know what
was not foreseen and part of the
challenge there there's a wonderful book
by Emanuel Derman about this and models
behaving badly which is that you know
the implications that are implicit it's
it's got this is probably too long a set
of words but the one articulated
implicit assumptions in financial models
or models more generally so how do we
you know add all those extra terms in
our our formula in our equations and
Inter algorithms that you know may not
capture precisely what we're leaving out
but at least raised a flag you know and
and make it explicit and and I think
again coming back to the point of the
data contract it's you know in fact in a
lot of contracts you know that they good
lawyers will write the contracts in such
a way that they do points to what's not
in the contract and you know I pick up
my cup of tea here and I see on the back
of my little man yogi car you are
unlimited and whether was limited or
unlimited I leave that to others to
judge and assess but being conscious of
constraints and limits where something
ends and where something begins yes that
I believe is what saves us or what helps
us you know avoid the banana skins and
the crises and the disjunctions and the
dystopian not that that come about and
and are responsible for human misery and
an abject misery in people and society
and communities yeah that's that's
interesting that the interconnectedness
of everything this Gaia hypothesis that
that notion and understanding of reality
is crucial for our footing in unity
simultaneously the where where something
starts and where something ends a
simultaneously extremely crucial for our
footing and then I found what you were
saying for the weather that that this
what we just said right there related to
the edge of knowledge is very important
because we see so many
things that are being published
scientifically that are not replicable
but right this is a major issue and at
the edge of knowledge so it's almost as
though the more that we focus on how we
can understand that limiting edge of
knowledge of civilizations collective
knowledge and how to best replicate and
push at that edge and understand where
certain scientific advancements start
where they end how we can maybe
translate to something else but that
edge the way we play at the edge is so
important for our for our long-term and
you started hinting at also the real
estate this is you were teaching me
about this as well there's so many
variables that actually go into this
that actually I think you were the first
person that that taught me about
obsolescence in real estate I hadn't
used that word we usually use that word
with the with the technologies but it's
interesting to think about a home like
the homes in Detroit for example some of
them just haven't had tenants for over a
decade or what not and the interiors are
in some ways you know collapsing and
stuff right and then you see all some of
these new homes be built and some of
these new homes are already equipped
with this you know okay Google
what's the population of Earth and now
it's like seven point eight almost and
more than that so the point is that now
we have this super cool way to embed
newest technologies in 2020s
technologies into our homes that make
them so then there's that then there's
the supply and demand of the properties
in the cities that they're located in
demand of people wanting to move there
there's all these things that you had to
crunch and this was you know with core
logic you were 13 years of oh yeah I
spent a lot of time on that and just to
chew on tread a little bit some of what
you said there I think again III
mentioned around this sort of paradigm
guided and I've wrestled with in terms
of you know singular plural and so on
and a lot of it as you were talking
there I just those those words of unity
and diversity came back to me right and
and both as as how you know as a set of
stressors in our in our lives in our
communities in our societies of you know
what is the relationship between unity
and diversity how they coexist how they
intimate with each other how they relate
to each other how the fact that you do
have to have both for stability and
growth and advancement and this is where
you know in the wider social context the
issue of identity of course is so
manifest currently now and and again and
into the whole set of
intersectionalities and the gradients
within those intersectionalities can
come about so it's it's it's really
really critical you know jumping to to
to the more you know the real estate of
property and and that side of things I
think you know you know we live in a
city herself a Cisco the greater Bay a
great great a Bay Area which has been
the subject of massive change over the
last five years and many many
communities and societies are
experiencing this what right across the
world particularly in urban areas yes
and I was just you know reflecting the
other day and there's a new building
going up I passed by and I remember the
building that was there before yeah
right and you know and again when we go
back to our home city or home street or
hometown is it still the same and so on
and of course it may it may not be so
the question is what are we getting
right and where is our voice in in in
what we can and how we get it and in
urban environments and this is where I
think you know politics and government
and and how a city is run and and you
know the voices that are at the table um
in making that possible are so important
because you know we're you know we can
all sit back and say where is it going
we don't know but but where are where
our voices we sit in addition in where
it's going in the decisioning and and in
particular that yes you know as a social
good housing real estate it for example
in in my own country in Ireland at the
moment there's a debate going on around
you know where but potentially there
being a fundamental right to housing and
incorporating that into the Constitution
but there is a right to shelter yes and
again I think you know we're all called
Maslow's hierarchy of needs and and
shelter is it's right at the core there
that we have a need but do we have a
right to be sheltered and then
consequently that is a social good that
the state and government and society
needs to make available to to every
member of the community
but then in terms of of of enabling that
in in a built environment and we're you
know the technology pleased to tear tear
it's your example there is that you know
the built environments that we we are
creating are gonna be clearly or
technologized and they've ever been and
part of the fabric of that built
environment is a set of networks and and
capabilities to do things within a room
to do things within a home that we're
never ever present before and that's
both the connector to other homes and
and our society more largely but it's
also you know we have to be very careful
I think sometimes that you know that
when an autonomy there is an isolating
or a self isolating effect of autonomy
right but we want to be autonomous but
do we want to be isolated right and you
know as we move to a built environment
where people may not shop anymore they
don't go to the mall and they go to the
mall SLS and things are delivered and
all of that and and we move more to that
sort of you know that kind of a desert
island type environment and are coming
this evil were stacked on top of each
other even though
exactly yeah and that our connectivity
and our communication is via exclusively
or largely to electronic means and
ensure our devices and I'm whatever up
so so the channels that were creating
the pipes that were creating and former
homes from our live spaces from our
shared live spaces and indeed the street
itself right the concept of the street
isn't just a an avenue for trajectory
and the street is a shared space yeah
right and and you know in an urban
environment in particular you know the
governance of that Shred space is
something as as a community that we we
all have to have a voice in but it's not
just utility it's something that we
actually share what are the people and
and there are people who live in that
space who are homeless or who are
whatever they're doing who show that
space with us as we goodbye in our daily
lives
meaning pointing out the voice related
to what is actually occurring with the
trajectory of civilization is such an
interesting question who's at the table
yeah who's at the table and you know and
again be mindful of who is not at the
table right who wasn't invited to the
table III I think in in in in advocacy
and any form of of innovation it's very
very important to come back to this kind
of error term I was mentioning in
analytics of what's being left out right
yeah and even if what's being left out
by definition doesn't have a voice at
the table but there's an articulation by
those who do have a voice at the table
to say you know what a isn't your B is
into your C isn't here to make it
manifest you know and that in turn is
assuring and then potentially an
invitation to those who don't have a
voice to come to the table and further
to be an enablement all of that if we
could reset and potentially redesign
civilization from scratch
these are the questions that we like
thinking about these reuse simulations
that it could be interesting to see how
if we would slow down and think could we
actually educate all of the children to
be completely well-rounded contributors
to the democracy though to the
Democratic Republic that we could
potentially live in as a union not right
right and and then the sort of weight of
that the data the valve the value of
that of that voice in becomes an
educated value there is as I can but
then that whole notion that everything
that we see is like unequal in some ways
that it's all hierarchical and by all
this is again I mentioned earlier who
says to contacts to sell and you know
his you know his people that he taught
but told about it in framing that he was
very influenced by the the watchmakers
of Geneva I think it was but this was
you know this Unitarian community and he
looked at that as a model for how you
know communities and policies and
society should be and you know in the
data contract you know what are our
ideal communities of shared value of
shared exchange you know and again
fundamental to your economics energy to
it to Marxism is one strand of that is
the the idea of exchange and of course
any transaction by definition has a you
know a bi-directional exchange of money
for goods or money for services that's
the whole basis of Commerce that it is
it is it is an exchange it is a
relationship it is on the it is a
sharing it is you know premise from set
of rules and when those rules are
distorted to folder missiles or you know
distortions in a market or an intercept
it an anticipated or unintended
consequences
that's I me all that you know tend to
suffer and yeah
get locked and lopped yes so the
relation to to data being trust and the
relation to even on like a real estate
finance side of things is that when you
bake in Ireland in the claws of giving
people access to homes as a human right
that the access to the home they get
will not be the multi-million dollar
beachfront property with the Chas the
brand newest technology which is also
very interesting on a on a
socio-economic and hierarchical
perspective of equality but also
difference and so these are the pressing
kind of questions that I that is really
cool to talk to you about in an abstract
way and then also getting down to a you
know not this isn't 90% of all the data
that is creatives created in the last
two years and just keeps doing that so
how do you structure this data make it
applicable to our lives especially on a
biometrics level right because we want
to be able to get to that one really
quickly well I live longer be more
creative contribute more live more with
happy times with our families and all
this good stuff right well it's
interesting to see you know there's a
number of movements and initiatives now
around for example just in in cognate
areas like ethics and artificial
intelligence for example you know how
algorithms you know sort of should there
be a Public Interest editor type
individual at the social media companies
you know who can represent you know
similar to a Public Interest editor a
newspaper excuse me who can represent
the voice of the of the Facebook user or
the Google search er you know in saying
you know these algorithms are in part of
public good right like the street like
the street that we share right it is
newsfeed is like the street wow it's
like a channel it's low it's a vector
it's a trajectory which people Sherman
you know and
you know this is I think I am as points
you worry about you know the tributaries
becoming the river right and a no great
river is on tribute Erised right in that
sense so I think it requires all of us
to join into the new speeder join into
the substrate that is that were the
tributaries leading into them yeah very
very much so and and of course in a
river it's the climate or the geology
that you know governs the rivulet sand
the the swamps or whatever way that that
water there the whole hydrology of that
right and you know it's its nature the
landscape but you know however you wish
to posit that but people are different -
right and the society it's different
because there you've got concept of
power and a concept of gradient and a
concept of representation obviously in
the democracy where we were where we
vote and enable in permission folks to
represent us and then you know when
that's how society is governed and
structured so yeah I love your analogy
on the tributaries in the river to me
that says a lot about how we have
different amounts of
water that it's also kind of like the
brightnesses of stars in our galaxy in a
sense as well that that one of us maybe
at one of the tributaries that leads in
that that in let's just pick like the
Dalai Lama or something right that is
trying to make this piece pull push the
unity push and someone else maybe trying
to make the same peaceful unity push but
with much smaller of a megaphone for
their voice so and then some people
might be still pursuing greed and
gluttony and those might be large river
or large tributaries that are pushing
into the river as well and then all
these things are mixing together in this
reality yeah I mean look people have
lines and people have priorities and
people need to get things done and it's
hella difficult to have a cosmic vision
when you're worried about the next
paycheck that's right and and then if
you have a cosmic vision then maybe you
don't need to then maybe your person who
never is worrying about that the next
paycheck right so III think you know the
sense of purpose and and purposing of
course individuals and people and
families and communities and whatever
their collectives are is is is is very
very important I think you know what
we've been talking about here very much
is around a shared space where voices
are both heard were both invited and
heard that error terms in this data
contract as I've been articulating are
are spoken and that over time they're
minimized
and that um you know the the idea of of
and again just coming back to the
finance piece real estate piece for a
second there again the last financial
crisis it was it was again I referenced
an invention of the man who Germans
Germans book about models behaving badly
that you know it now every bank for
example of a large bank will have a team
of people photo focus just on model risk
the risk in the model itself
and that's something that's regulated
and that's something that DC pays
attention to so you know maybe that's an
appropriate paradigm to apply to social
media algorithms or recommendation
engines or how search is done yes right
that that we actually have you know a
set of folks whose job is is to identify
that risk articulate that risk
communicate that risk and then have a
set of rules and compliance or whatever
it may be around
how about algorithm or set of algorithms
is actually deployed you know and I
think fundamentally that is good for any
democratic society or any society that
you face or that is committed to to
share values interesting the risk in the
model having error in actually having
that be primary focus in algorithms
that's really cool I'd absolutely and I
think that was you know one of the you
know the the big regulatory changes post
the the the financial crisis I mean
there's always been some of that for
sure but it was codified in a much more
systematic way I think also you know
it's your point about the
interconnectedness with in the financial
system financial markets how that
ultimately touches consumer as borrowers
and so on it's it's it's the whole piece
of of you know whack-a-mole right where
you think you've you imagine a carpet on
the floor that hasn't been laid
correctly there's a little bubble or as
a lump on it right and of course you
walk on it you can push that bubble and
hub somewhere else and not see it it
could be under your chair can be under
the couch right and when you take it
when you take the furniture and that's
oh hey there it is right but you've got
a finite boundary there so I think part
of of analytics and investigation and
indeed good governance in the state of
contract is very much around well where
are those humps and bumps and moles and
whatnot in the carpet because that may
be the origin of the next crisis aka
dystopia
a KA you know abjection in terms of that
what's happening to our communities in
society
yeah and I love it when people speak
with these powerful analogies like
that's a new one to me too as the humps
in the carpet kind of a lot of times we
do just sweep things under the right but
this is where you know whatever some of
the comfort that's a little bit to one
side isn't the carpets itself hasn't
been fishing properly which is also an
interesting analogy with a bottle and
goodness official as we call it in
statistic mr. fish yes fit right that
that the model is a good fit to the data
but not over fit it or under fit it and
and and that point which which model
risk is is largely about enhance the
fact that the model is representation of
reality is that the model has stability
in other words when new data is
presented to it and hence when the model
is stressed that it's still stable that
it still works that it still performs
above a given threshold and the more and
more we can include in you know in our
you know in our modeling in our in our
in our formation of algorithms and our
governments of algorithms about what it
doesn't do as much as what it does to
and that where it is weak and very
strong and making that manifest in
communicating that then I think we have
a richer assured space for decisioning
and happiness and and effectiveness and
productivity and all things that we want
that that's where it all starts this
takes us again to the clickability of
this massive waterfall this fire
hydrants so that's happening with the
data data explosion explosion you're
making it applicable okay and this seems
to be a decent amount of what you're
doing with the molybdenum teach us about
this teach us about exactly how what
we've been talking about is is the
essence of this working with these
massive organizations that want these
key insights yeah so we say let's
finance arts and you know part of
happiness is its putting on the screen
what you like to do I guess you know
so maybe that's that what what I'm doing
here and I think you know we've talked a
lot about data math analytics and so on
and I think for the financial system of
which the real estate is is is a is an
extension and particularly the financing
of real estate which is kind of you know
my professional interest for that I
spend most of my time on and how it can
come about that you know we've talked
about homes to vote environment what's
happening in that space but but the
financing of that is largely you know if
you think about credit or a loan it is
largely about actualizing now what
actualizing now and owning now and
having benefit from now that is out of
sync with you know the financial assets
of that person in that community right
but so by definition you wouldn't need a
loan or have a loan already form of
credit if you had those financial
resources or you may choose not to use
your financial resources and instead
take credit or a loan instead right but
obviously that loan has to be paid back
over time and that's where the old idea
of an interest rate coupon comes about
in excuse me in the financing so you
know when when there's a decision that
is a credit decision you're you're
making a projection about the future you
can making a you know a set of
hypotheses around the creditworthiness
of that of that enterprise of that
individual of that household in order to
you know make their home and where they
live it mean you know you know a reality
so I think you know it's it's a very
very data-intensive data rich area now
because of computational power and the
reduction in the economics of the cost
or the changes in the cost of
computation applied to that we now have
access to as you said a whole set of
data and jail elements and yet explosion
and the cocoa into those decisioning and
those decision engines scoring engines
and whatnot that we never ever had
before and I think um you know again
as Alice and scientists we always have
to be confident that you know these are
representations of reality and so again
coming back to the point that I've
mentioned several times in this
conversation you know there is much
about what is left out as what is
included you know inclusion and
exclusion and being very very manifest
about that I think where the art comes
here in here for me as the molybdenum is
is and again it brings us right back to
to that analogy was that a metaphor is
around the lenses and in the petition I
just to the ophthalmologist is and again
you know data visualization information
visualization has been talked about and
been around for many many years of
reading a doctor to an app of course
which is the visualization of all of
geography and real estate I mean I would
when he goes back to at all may you know
2,000 years ago right but you know
cartography itself of course is is
political and as a set of choices and in
embeds power and and indeed you know in
this network ization that we've touched
on several times in this conversation
there is also been I would submit an ace
death Association as well that there's a
you know which is maybe too fancy a word
for for things being aesthetic for
aesthetics or you know being beautified
or being you know endowed a richer
visual content absolutely that which we
kind of see in all these little sci-fi
movies these gorgeous data
visualizations yeah absolutely and I
think you you know this is not an
appropriation of art or visualization
but it's actually looking at that as a
tool to help our communities see better
yeah right and in many ways it's it's go
right back to them it's a modernism you
know in and out in the early 20th
century I think it was a you know
Kandinsky possibly Kandinsky and in his
book concerning the spiritual concerning
the spiritual and art said that that the
task of the artist isn't to render the
visual but to make visual you know
that's that's it significant part of
what I'm trying to wrestle with in this
molybdenum sandbox yeah you know what it
what is the way to you know and I don't
see that as revealing or you know going
up to that to the top of the mountain
and invading the drum but it's it's it's
sort of you know making manifest making
manifest and and using a set of visual
and mathematical and analytic and data
languages to bring clarity and you know
we started I think a little bit early in
this conversation around questioning and
the and and the generative quality of
questioning and how it takes us forward
how how did how it advances us so I
really see the the the mechanics and the
tools of visualization and helping us be
better visualizers meaning that were
that enables a richer way to to come to
the shared space because you know in my
Galileo virtual practical we're all
looking through that telescope yeah okay
so then is it fair than to say that a
lot of what you are caring about with
the molybdenum is helping people see
through that telescope see through to a
more beautiful way of understanding data
a more knowledgeable way yeah it's more
eligible way of understanding what
they're doing in the world and and and
and looking at data and data languages
and model and model languages as giving
providing richer vocabulary to describe
the world you know that that that a lot
of it again it's that generative quality
that you know that we expand our
vocabularies we expand our tools you
know it's our color palette it's not
just the tree you know it's the color
wheel it's not just you know that the
blue red and white or the red white and
green
whatever it may be but it's that full
spectrum that that
that expands our you know our vision and
our positioning in the world and how we
relate to others and how we provide
services and goods you know enterprises
or people in communities so the
beautification piece you know and I
don't see beauty and aesthetics as being
the one thing I think they are a bit you
know there isn't a an auto overlap there
I think the with beauty and and the
appeal and all of the kind of warm and
fuzzies of that that that's that's
something that still I think requires
its own you know piece of work in terms
of understanding its height width and
breadth and and the seduction of that
and and the constraints of that I think
are as important as as much as the yeah
the appeal okay now I want to ask you
about the technical side of things sure
okay so how does one take this firehose
of data and help people see it with a
better lens right it's it's a big
question and a great question
and in indeed in some respect as an
analyst it's a lifetime's question you
know and and and we - quest you know
because there's almost like an inbuilt
recursion to it and you know again I
mentioned philosophy science I think
Karl Popper I think entitled it is is is
autobiography only ended question
requested on ended quest you know a
little bit more you know and you also
point to something interesting on a
technical level which is that if you
look at code written 60 years ago 40
years ago 20 years ago even five years
ago that there has been this process of
needing to new coding languages coming
in they're amazing easier open-source
technologies and so the way that things
just move makes it quite difficult then
to be able to make something in did in
the digital space that can last for
decades and right in the well that this
is the classic you know in built
obsolescence
right dad dad you know there's this this
you know Trojan not in that malicious
code sense but that there's something
already inbuilt that is going to auto
destruct or you know auto decay or
basically make it have less utility or
less value right that that and that you
know that managers should be good with
that we should know that we should
accept that yeah you know and you know I
think if you talk to to to any any
product manager worth his or her salt
change is good
yeah but but also you know let's be
explicit about our Sun setting you know
we know days gonna turn in tonight we
mean we know that you know a cell phone
and mobile phone will be carried around
with you so you know a part of the the
you know the the real worry about
utopias is that they they tend to be
bundled with infinity right and they
they don't last right that they come to
an end and again you you know in terms
of questioning and you know I think one
of the you know I'll come back to your
core question in a second but but you
know confusion in part is around blurred
limits right and blurred constraints and
not seeing or not having the tools
having the enablers to see things more
sharply delineated right and I think
part of now I will come back to your
question part of this whole data machine
my Loranger
you know big soda bread of data is is is
making the constituent segments and its
boundaries more clear you know more
clear and I think you know you know when
you step out of the details of a lot of
what we've chatted about I would you
know they're kind of leaves you with one
takeaway thing is is that you know
clarity is
a prize a huge priority cardi how do you
draw those lines though how do you
figure out where to say that this is out
of the massive fire hose out of the
massive spectrum of data that we're
gonna take this node we're gonna take
these right right and we're gonna and
we're gonna visualize them in this way
and how do you do that it has to be
relative to a set of criteria yeah right
which is you know what are the important
thing is what are we actually trying to
get done what what are the the important
things that that this is all about is
through a business example yeah so so
you know it is a form of assessment and
judgment you know that that and again I
mentioned this point earlier in data
science that we we usually build our
models from a principle of parsimony
which is you know the least amount of
data having the maximum utility right
that's so great right and also data that
has the maximum explanatory power right
and I'll try less and and this is a
challenge for example English in some
areas with imitating machine learning
that you know these models are also good
you know they're so high performing you
know all-singing all-dancing but can
they explain what's going on right do we
really have a sense and I think you know
right at the heart of science is a
satisfaction that that we understand
right and and there is a sort of we get
say [ __ ] by that it's after like having
a good glass of nice meal it's mmm you
know and when completing something hard
in some of it yeah we don't have that
we're a little bit disconsolate and we
want to go back and do it again you know
and I think sometimes that is a
trade-off between you know the
performance the predictability the
efficacy of an analytic model and its
intelligibility right or particular to a
business person or to a consumer or to
someone who isn't a data scientist or
you know or or code or
who isn't going to see the innards of
how as something is doing and I think
that's why you know the odd that what I
call the public space or the quasi
public space you know of over say social
media algorithm is silver you know or an
algorithm that affects decisioning is
very very important that people have you
know have some sense of why this
decision was made right there and they
may not have their hands on that wheel
you know we don't all need to you know
be able to be can all go on a cruise
without knowing how to captain the ship
right but we trust a captain and we
trust that crew and that's what the debt
contract is trusting I did that because
I'm the data that because how when do
you trust the black box is the question
and like how do we build ecosystems of
human flourishing where black boxes
exist that we trust well and I want you
to get into also that sure the
nitty-gritty hi thank you for mentioning
the black box because it's it's it's
very very prevalent and you know from
from one Pat or from one standpoint one
might say look it you can never track to
be I'm sorry you can never trust a black
box
by definition its opaque and how can you
have trust if there isn't some form of
transparency you know on the other end
of the scale or spectrum to keep our
color right now is you going we might
say well every black box should be a
white box um but maybe my boxes don't
have content because they're all
elimination you know so maybe there's a
gray box you know maybe there's a maybe
there's a gray box which you know gray
isn't necessarily the most exciting of
coats from like you said some people
know how to captain the ship and but how
yeah yes so that gray box you know which
may be the sort of visual of the did
contract that I've been talking about
maybe that's good enough you know maybe
that that respects the proprietary
nature I
he or secret sauce or trade secrets you
know if the providers it's not you know
in commerce um but it gives us enough
clarity or enough D confusion or own
confusion to be able to trust it and to
make a transaction and have exchange for
goods services relationship so it's
awful if it becomes the monopoly where
we can't actually engage with it and aim
draw help contribute to it that can
change things that's right and and I you
know I can respect that you have black
boxes you can respect that I have black
boxes but how do we build a grey box
together right and if we don't build a
good box together then maybe we won't do
business with each other maybe we'll be
friends may go to relationship we do
will be associates or acquaintances
whatever that is
so so I think that's you know and and
you know whether it's black gray or
white the key point is illumination
illumination shining yeah yeah right
it's it's it's that um you know Supreme
Court justice I forget at their name or
palate Court justice who who said you
know in in reference to some famous case
that was litigated before the court that
um you know is it either sunlight or
sunshine is the best disinfectant oh
that was a great one yeah that was a
great one yes Sun lights the best is
some illumination again is that's what
we need an illumination from inside this
is yourself work that we also need to
slow down right to me that's where you
bring in in a way valuable yet that that
in in in commerce and society and
relationship that authenticity is
generating your own light and it's it's
self generated and then it's an
invitation to pay look at my life sure
in my life yes okay I'd like to do that
with you too
yes right and that is the grounds I
believe of you know a lot ends of life
a kind of eyes and an authentic practice
of professional practice or whatever one
is doing in the world okay so take us
through let's get through this as quick
as we can what happens when does usually
a company have a swath of of
unstructured data and then they talk to
you and then what language is that data
stored in ah it's it's it's it's it's
all of the go-fast so you know in some
cases people have you know a surfeit of
data both internally to their
organization or enterprise or what's
coming at them through the world or to
the competitors or to the regulators
whatever it may be in some cases they
feel they don't have the right data that
there's something missing you know so
it's it's it's it's all of the above and
you know my task as it is a scientist
and an analyst and in working with it
would a team and collaborators is to
again bring clarity to that you know
what is there and what is needed and
then ultimately you know bringing those
into a relationship with each other that
that the ones on the needs are solved
for true a process into a framework that
can bring them the desired outcome ok so
then there's this massive swath of data
they have a desire and need etc they
work with you and then what usually then
is your process for for having the data
for taking the data and then through
what language are you then visualizing
yeah sure yeah yeah so there's a number
of steps or sub steps within that part
of all of the initial approaches is is
an inventory you know what is there so
that there's actually you know a single
source of the Encyclopedia if you like
of the internal external data that's
gonna be germane to to what the problem
of their business object and what's like
a code is that usually really it can be
again anything over the Sun it can be
you know it can be it can be in a sequel
database it could be in you know in or
it could be a cloud structure it could
be on pram you know depending on on the
the the legacy did warehouses or data
repositories within the organization it
could be open source a well you know
what never goes in with with a cookie
cutter oh yeah yeah you know let's check
these boxes
you you you go in with a white piece of
paper and then you listen and you
understand and then Yes Doctor formal
and those legacy ones are harder to work
with sometimes and then you know and
then your way of working with sequel or
these different sort of data to be able
to cut take and visualize it do you use
a sink can you use a single language to
take in the data and play it again
sometimes sometimes not you know and
certainly you know this goes back to it
my work in dated the nineties we like to
form what we call a single view right so
that all of the key data elements that
we need to build an analytic and hence
you know solve a problem or achieve a
business objective that they are in the
one place now they may not be physically
in the one place or indeed in virtually
in the one place but from a data model
standpoint we have our arms around the
path to use it to use it in that way and
an important part of that process and
you know further step in the process is
to execute what we call a date audit
right so that we that be basically sort
of point or pointer or set of lenses at
that data to understand you know its
range to understand its quality to
understand its its sourcing to
understand its bias all right
because again jumping way way ahead to
building a model or an algorithm on that
data and indeed this is a very very
prominent for example in in ethics work
in AI at the moment you know bias how do
we get visibility on bias and what's the
self bias in that you can't understand
bias in a model or an algorithm without
understanding the sourcing because who
decides what the sourcing is who makes a
choice for multiple data elements from
that source to be part of the yes and
box in which the algorithm is computed
so you know you have to go it's kind of
like saying sometimes you gotta make
sure you
you go right back to the start to
understand you know because to my mind
data is is a memorialization of a
transaction right whether that's the
view of a webpage or the purchase of a
cup or you know the age of a person you
know it's basically capturing an event
right or point in time so if you're
ultimately building a set of analytics
architecture an architectonic
on that that ultimately is going to
drive a decision you dam is better well
know where that data comes came from and
Haverly what it actually represents so
you know there is a I think he used this
this term yourself alum and some of your
work you know that the mathematics of
sociology right dad fine you have a
model at the end of the day and charts
and graphs and all of the apparatus of
that but ultimately particularly the
area of consumer consumer behavior as it
touches in finance or mortgages or real
estate and so on it's about people
you know it's about understanding what
people have done and what people have a
propensity to do and what people may do
and you know so you need to be very very
you need to be in a place where you can
speak and articulate that through the
language of models and data and that's
really you know my fundamental oh what
what I work you know teams and
collaborators it's really to you know
try to discern that voice listen that
voice articulate that voice but use a
set of tools and data Anna likes to give
voice yes let's well synthesized I'm so
so curious about all of the millions of
applications of wanting to query data
sets and how to visualize those and and
what exactly are these key insights that
can be pulled from the data sets and how
do you go through the techniques of
properly doing so there's all very very
interesting to me
yeah on the point if I may you you know
we may well move to a position in our
society in our communities of you know
what I'll call ourself and data
governance you know who owns our date
who controls our data that you know if
you if you think of the early economist
you know the physiocrats in the 1516
17th century
you know fundamentally the it was land
that was the asset right pre-industrial
revolution right that that won't that's
what you know governed power in society
who owned land who an asset who had
access to land who had rights on land
who created value from land fast forward
to now 2019 and beyond
medi-date here perhaps data is the new
land you know yeah is a physical ground
right now we're in your studio doing
that but I stand on my data at the
moment in time what Damian Walden's
doing is a precious point indeed oh how
well and everybody exactly yeah
so then the interesting way of of
potentially seeing data then is one of I
think the most interesting ways is that
then the the greatest the second
greatest invention that we have is our
data and that we leave behind and the
first greatest invention is how to
actually measure that and make it
applicable to our lives and then that
second the second greatest invention
happens with all seven point eight
billion of us every single moment to
moment but the first greatest one hasn't
really been invented and that's how to
make it applicable and then what we're
seeing a lot I saw movie recently had to
train your dragon you know it's a how to
train your data you know how to grow
yeah that's you know all of that that
you know we teach children quite
properly to learn to read
to do math you you know the yeah on the
syllabus you know in in all areas of
education but you know I believe that
will come a point and this is my my
future Issel futures projection here is
is at an appropriate point in pedagogy
you know hey I have data you know what
am i doing you know how can I help me
live my life where do i who wants to
take that from me
you know yeah let me paint the last let
me paint the last part of that that
phrase that I was just going to the the
end of that thought was in this kind of
place right into what you were just
saying it's just that once we have that
that greatest invention about how to
make that data applicable is that then
we have what we can call this what
happens after that which is who owns
that data which is where we're both
heading there and you can see things as
a valve if you own the data you can go
and start releasing some of the valves
and giving the access to certain
organizations to start potentially
anonymously or completely transparently
you using that data to make medical
advancements or other research
advancements etc good stuff good stuff
there's also the alternative method
which is in a way a little bit more kind
of crazy is that black box method where
it's just the the owners of the
substrate that Google or Baidu or China
or US or whoever is the one that just
controls it period and you get no access
to use like self-governance way but you
just trust that entity to do it so
that's kind of this this big-picture
data what is gonna happen and what are
we gonna pass down to kids for the next
generation and I have some questions on
the way out do you have any wrapping
thoughts prior to questions and maybe
we'll wrap okay W or AP and or AP yeah
intertwined for those questions cool
alright so let's hit the first one that
I want to ask you is are we alone in the
cosmos well
I'm a little bit of an antiquarian so if
I've referenced a folks from the 16th
century 19th century and so on and I'm
gonna be a little bit chauvinistic and
reference an Irish philosopher George
Berkeley
in the 17th century and you know just
pluck and pick out something that's a
little bit of a par phrase of what he
wrote but are we a dream and in the mind
of God you know which I mean yeah it's
very much linked to your your your
simulation impulse and you know you're
situated in the world in the world Allen
and you know to me I would reframe that
question it's not so much gonna be alone
in the world but what it were wrestling
with a little bit but it's it's more
around you know isolation as a synonym
for low maintenance right and you know
that I'm whether I'm good or not with
weather alone I sure as hell don't want
to be isolated and I think you know that
connectivity that it that if one has and
one owns and want inculcates and
cultivates a sense of connection and
connectivity with whatever and hopefully
something that's beneficial that that
that solves for that further for that
question and as long as that is is
generative or Otto generative and in the
questioning way that we've been talking
about it
that Bennett I don't know I feel pretty
good pretty cool yeah and then that
leads us to the simulation question are
we in a simulation well if we are I want
to make sure that I have my hand on the
joystick or my hands on the wheel and
again it comes back to the point of
voice and being at the table you know
you know there's this interesting
concept more than interesting concept
now of the digital twin and you know and
and and you know which goes back to
doubt the whole you know second line
from persona creation and them you know
snapchat and so on you you know these
are you know borderless simulacrum and
yeah and all of that and you know that
this is the whole idea of this
simulation in some sense is a self
authorization right yes so it's a little
bit like an idempotency that you know we
go out to return to ourselves and if
that's a conscious journey and a
conscious choice that we you know
creator or simulation or part of a
simulation in order to come back to our
true ourselves or more authentic cells
then yeah sign me up mmm like that
that's a meta perspective on it yeah
it's the growth we're constantly going
towards that growth house property to
get there okay
two more this one is what would be a
best principal or core value that you
think would be very important for
parents and children around the world
gosh
acceptance acceptance to come into
acceptance with yourself as a human
being and to come into acceptance with
those around you and from that point of
acceptance that's where all change and
growth happens
you're laughing
because it feels right you know it feels
right it feels true fuels were accepting
the current state of humanity in the
current state of all individuals for the
way it is and then we're always doing
our best to make it better for the next
show
yeah it's it's a little bit reductionist
about it it's it's kind of before the
future that has to be the present that
the starting point is now and the most
stable starting point is acceptance and
an equanimity with what is around us and
what is internal to us less than and
that's forge of equanimity then gives us
the best chance or the best toolkit or
whatever yes to to them come into a
relationship even keel just just I'm so
in love with the current state yeah the
warm breeze in wall marie's well Damian
last question is what he thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world I think the
most beautiful thing in the world is the
can I say - yeah I would pick love and
the overcoming of loss and that those
two things are very closely related at
school and that you know that passion
which we of you know it's bound to put
love and compassion which is about the
overcoming of loss and grief to my mind
though things are really ultimately the
same thing passion and compassion
love and and getting through the loss
and overcoming loss that's very powerful
learning to learn ID so any true eristic
is about making mistakes right it's
about spending time on something that
wasn't productive or didn't yield
something now that's a very kind of
fancy fancy way of saying loss yeah
right in a life in a community in a
society but there can be no learning
there can be no growth without loss um
so you know acceptance is also about
accepting loss and also about accepting
love Danny and I love this this is so
good thank you so much for teaching us
about this as a pleasure it's been such
a pleasure this has been such an honor
having you on the show I really
appreciate it thank you for your
kindness and inviting me today you are
you're super welcome you're super
welcome back anytime there's so much to
still talk about data and understanding
this that's like a big big firehose and
like and how to be able to make it
applicable to our lives and and and just
and just also on the philosophy side of
things it's been such a pleasure yeah it
down an abstract civilizational
perspective thank you everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate you we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below let us know what you're
thinking also do support awesome artists
and entrepreneurs that you believe in
Damien's links are below our links are
below go check out his work check out
our work as well and go and build the
future everyone to manifest your dreams
into the world we love you so much thank
you for tuning in and we will see you
soon
peace